all right the Border battle down in
Texas intensifies with Democrats now
calling on the President Joe Biden to
federalize the State National Guard but
Governor Greg Abbott is not backing down
saying Texas has the right to defend
itself against the migrant Invasion and
they're using the Constitution as a
weapon Lucas Tomlinson is live in
Washington with the details all right
Lucas unwind this all right well good
morning my friends the Texas border
standoff continues both Governor Greg
Abbott and the White House refusing to
back down now GOP reinforcements are
pouring in Abbott receiving the support
of many of his fellow Republican
Governors such as Florida Governor Ron
de santis Virginia governor Glenn yunin
South Dakota Governor Christie gome also
the governors from Oklahoma Montana
Georgia and Utah now some on the left
when President Biden to do more Texas
Congressman waim Castro says Biden needs
to take control of the Texas National
Guard right now other Democrats russan
his defense are Congressman Greg casar
and former congressman and former
gubernatorial candidate in Texas B oror
and invoking the father of the
Constitution James Madison as Steve said
off the top and Alexander Hamilton by
the way it's outrageous there's not a
statute of him in St Croy but I digress
Texas governor Greg abber responding
with a scathing statement accusing Biden
being a lawless president saying quote
the executive branch of the United
States has a constitutional duty to
enforce federal laws protecting States
including immigration laws on the books
right now President Biden has refused to
enforced those laws and has even
violated them the result is that he has
smashed records for illegal immigration
and this comes of course as the Border
bill in the Senate is in danger of
falling apart which allows thousands of
migrants into the country each day it
has drawn the eyer of many house members
including some Republican Senators as
well guys hey Lucas you know is this the
first time in in modern American history
where the United States government which
is in charge of keeping us safe is is
being accused by a state for allowing
people to come in uh with little to no
vetting and and things like that
essentially Texas is saying there's an
invasion and so ultimately it becomes a
question for the courts of what
constitutes safe because the people of
Texas say we're not safe and Steph I
think that's one of the reasons why
President Biden only has an 18% approval
rating with his handle of the Southern
border according to a recent ABC newsp
uh many in America want to see that
southern border fortified thanks Lucas
no kidding well if you look at the har
the Harvard Harris polls it says this is
the new issue that has overtaken
inflation and we have different ideas of
how to fix it Republicans say that uh
it's like 85% of them say that it's got
81% say the conditions are getting worse
On the Border but only 45% of Democrats
agree with that even John fedman the
progressive Senator out of Pennsylvania
he's a Democrat he's calling this a
crisis and he said the Senate and
Congress have to deliver on this border
security situation I don't understand
why this is controversial he said he
made the best point he said look at the
numbers in December we had 300,000
encounters he said that's larger than
the city of Pittsburgh and he said and
that is just one month that's right so
Brian it looks like that this is going
back to the courts again this is what
Texas is saying according to according
to Article 5 section4 the states the
federal government has a Duty right to
protect each state from any type of
invasion and if you look at our border
and our live chots every single day at
the border it's very clear that Texas is
being invaded by several countries he's
saying that this is the governor who
used to be the Attorney General of Texas
he's saying because you have failed to
do Article 5 section 4 we're going to
use Article 1 Section 10 section clause
three to enforce that so essentially is
saying that if the federal government
refuses to protect any state we have the
right right through whatever National
Guard or Texas Department of Public
Safety to defend ourselves right listen
to this so the Governor of Oklahoma
stands with him the governor of Montana
the governor of Georgia the governor of
uh of Florida they're all saying we're
with you Texas we get it we're 100% with
you now if you want to get some momentum
for any type of legitimate Border
Protection that's been worked on now by
Senator Langford Senator Murphy heading
it up and you say and the president
comes out and says it is a crisis we got
to fix it if you really want to know if
they're sincere why would anyone think
the president sincere about it when he's
doing everything he can to cut the razor
wire that Texas is forced to do
themselves and setting in the federal
government to do it why would anyone
feel good about it when he is backing up
all those cities that have Sanctuary
status now if you look at if you look at
the inverse of what we're doing at the
border for what teex doing at the border
think about these cities are trumping
the constitution in these Sanctuary City
status you're saying I don't care what
the federal government says we are
forbiding ice from kicking out people
who we know are here illegally from even
asking him that's also unconstitutional
but the president Stakes his uh Stakes
his uh Power and sends the courts in our
legal system after states that just want
to hold on to their sovereignty and
protect their people listen I I saw
something in the New York Post yesterday
we were up uh in New England so we did
we missed it but I picked it up today
you know the migrants are winding up in
this country with preloaded debit cards
and envelopes of cash right know yeah
you know where that money is coming from
it's coming from the United States of
America let me explain how all of us
America's taxpayers are paying for those
people to come across at Razer wire the
New York Post has his story it talks
about how the United Nations has got
this uh inter agency platform for
refugees and migrants from Venezuela and
they've got $1.6 billion uh to help
people reach the US Mexican border and
so that razor wire slows them down and
so they don't like that and so the
United Nations you know they've given
all these people money to make it to the
southern border that's slowing them down
so what's Joe Biden doing he's making it
easier for them to come in and here Angy
is the important part with the United
Nations we've talked about this for
decades who's the biggest funer of the
United Nations the United States
absolutely we pay 22% of the UN budget
so keep in mind we are financing most a
lot of those people we're financing more
than any other country on the globe
those people to come into this country
illegally this you know and for so we're
going to play the sound bite in a moment
of KLA Harris talking about how the
Republicans have made this a political
thing to run on look look what Joe Biden
is doing he's taking our taxpayer money
putting it in their pockets and saying
come on to the United States Republicans
want the problem fixed finally democ
getting on board and the reason is Tom
homman said it's because Fox News has
been pushing this so so conservatives
know about this issue we're seeing it in
our cities you're seeing it in Texas
we're seeing it all over the South but
now Democrats are seeing it because now
other channels have to cover it because
it's coming to States like New York and
it's coming to big cities like Chicago
and all these Governors are saying we
don't have the money in fact our mayor
here in New York City is now saying
federal government give me help I need
help now so now it's an issue that
everyone in our country Democrats and
Republicans are noticing and seeing and
KLA Harris is saying that Republicans
are just using this so they can win
elections no Republicans had been
screaming saying help us our country is
being invaded by not only illegal
immigrants and you have to foot the bill
but also by criminals that are bringing
in drugs by terrorists and Tom homman
said there are terrorists in our country
listen to what our vice president is
trying to
say some people seem fixated on Joe
Biden's age but I wanted to ask you it's
cuz they have nothing to run on Katie
well immigration now they're running on
to which they could actually participate
in fixing right and so no but really you
know so yeah you're right they're
running on immigration because they like
having the problem so they can they can
have an issue we hope and and and and
are really trying to
compel um in particular some of the
republicans in Congress to participate
in the solution but sadly I you know we
want to fix it they want to run on it
they want to they want a political issue
to run on in November she has so no
interest in trying to fix it she only
went there once for an hour uh went to
the border and left one of the biggest
embarrassments when you realize how
useless she was when she basically
punted when asked to take control of the
Border like Vice President Biden was
asked by Barack Obama to his credit uh
whatever the policy they had he actually
did something and for Katie KK not to
ask don't you feel responsible for the
worst disaster in America American
history at the southern border is is
crazy I'm not sure if she's still with
the Today Show but uh the other thing
with with uh with kamla Harris is almost
everything that kamla Harris and Joe
Biden can do right now could affect the
border and help their political fortunes
just reverse the amnesty problem reverse
the parole do the remain in Mexico you
don't need Congress for that at all you
don't need any more money for that at
all you could get additional money to to
uh adjudicate quickly for people but if
you change the questions that they're
ask to the Border you can no longer come
in here and say I'm being threatened in
my country then we that's enough to stay
now you say it doesn't matter go to
another section of your country if you
don't have proof you're being pursued
you can't stay that would do something
I'm just baffled by the headline the
Republicans have nothing to run on I
mean immigration is just number one on
top of the list you got inflation you
got National Security you got what
happened in Afghanistan I mean we can
just keep going over and over and the
fact that you have a reporter right
there that is supposed to be
representing the American people and our
interest on a day-to-day basis not push
back and say what about these issues I
think is stunning well you know what
when when the Joe Biden team uh came up
with their game plan for the 2024 race
immigration migration and these images
from Fox and now they're on every
channel in every Big City because the
sanctuary cities they weren't counting
on that uh they were going to run on it
you know we're we're being inclusive uh
and now it's like the people of the
states are going please turn it off we
were all at the Boston airport yesterday
did you realize that Boston's got such a
a migrant problem that just like Chicago
now they're keeping the migrants at the
airport simply because and we all know
it's freezing out there going to be
interviewing it's warm about that later
right I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis